Hey,
what's going on is bill bird.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 8th,
2019 still want to say 18,
2019 what's going on?
How the fuck are you?
How was your God damn weekend?
Um,
you know,
when people ask you a question or there some of you still a bit about that.
They just asked you a question so they can fucking say what they want to say.
Okay.
How are you doing on,
it's got gray.
Okay.
I'm asking you how your weekend is gone cause I,
I'm,
I'm fucking,
uh,
coming up on next week.
This Saturday.
Everybody thinks the big story this week.
The big fucking story.
What are they talking about?
Oh,
oh,
the fucking NCAA finals game.
Oh,
baseball's done.
The way all the NHL playoffs are starting,
that'd be A's right around.
Everybody thinks those are the big story.
I would Trump fired somebody else.
Oh,
there's chaos in Libya.
Okay.
Somebody fucking stepped on somebody's toe and Canada and didn't apologize.
Now they've been canceled.
Canadian Twitter.
Everybody thinks those are the big stories.
Those are not all right.
I,
I'm ashamed of volume.
If you think that these stories are bigger than the fact that all freckles has
gone 19 weeks without drinking and coming up this weekend,
that's 20 weeks.
Two zero baby.
I'm almost halfway fucking there.
Just like that.
Yeah,
the man shut it down.
So there you go.
While you a motherfuckers out there trying to say,
I was one of you that I needed this whole gang of people that help me fucking
walk out of a bar like Kellen Winslow after that fucking Miami Dolphin game.
I don't need you fucking people.
I get control when I decide.
When I say it's over,
it's fucking over.
And they sang about booze.
All right.
Okay.
A Bose has no respect for fucking alcoholics.
He sees you.
He sees you weak.
It's like when Tyson would win it,
the whole fight and the fucking stare down.
That's the best.
That bottle of booze staring at you.
Fucking gay people now me.
Okay.
I'm a tougher breed of an alcoholic and what's known as a binge drinker.
It's the switch man.
Flip it on a flip it off.
Okay.
And I'm the,
I'm the man touching the socket.
I ain't know what I'm saying.
I'm just psyched.
I'm like halfway through.
I'm not trying to make funny you fucking a people.
I feel bad for a people,
you know.
Everybody gave a shit what they,
what they had to say and about all of their stories.
Pre nine 11 and then after nine 11 it all went to hell.
Right?
Then it was all about supporting the troops.
You know,
the first responders.
Now it's all the way down to like fucking mailmen and mail lady say they're all
in front of Ya.
Everybody forgot I brought our fallen heroes,
the raging alcoholics and all of their goddamn stairs.
Man.
Ben,
I remember that pre fuck.
What the fuck?
I can't even talk anymore.
Pre nine 11 how many fucking movies did they make about alcoholics?
Okay,
Eh,
Ali's fucking movies.
All right.
I can't think of any right now.
Barfly yeah.
Okay.
Leaving Las Vegas.
Oops,
I did it again,
right?
Was that the soundtrack?
Britney spears ward a soundtrack to a drunk booby.
I figured out what the fuck it was.
Right?
But that was all these fucking movies about these alcoholics and how they gay
code and do this and they couldn't do that.
And they get all fucking,
you know,
and they're there.
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
People.
I'm just trying to fill up an hour while annoying a circuit,
certain segment of the population decided today I decided it was going to be
alcoholics.
Come on.
We've all lived with one.
Ah,
they're fucking excuses.
Always blaming the bottle.
It's like 20% wasn't you?
The silver and I'm staring at right now.
20% of that fucking shit wasn't you.
It's all in the bottle.
Like a little Janie.
You just put it right bay.
But Babe Adelabu fucking Bourbon.
Is it print Sally?
Fabulous.
He,
oh,
that movie's like offensive,
I think to the Middle Eastern people.
You know what I mean?
It's a weird one,
right?
Hollywood thinks that we're,
we're,
we're magical and fly on carpets.
All right,
well I can see.
Well,
you know,
that's not really trading like a human big,
but,
uh,
it's a lot better than they treat a lot of people in Hollywood.
Some other groups and trade a little bit worse.
Uh,
anyways,
I don't know.
Why do I comment on things?
I don't,
I,
you know,
I just see shit and I immediately think,
hey,
I have an opinion.
I haven't read up on anything.
God Damn,
I'm,
I'm having a great time right now because we are uh,
we are on episode nine,
number nine of season four,
episode family.
And uh,
I can't tell you what's happening,
but some people end up in this city that I had to do some research on.
I found out all this cool shit about it.
You know,
you know,
you don't me.
All right?
You don't know me.
You think you know me and I think I know me,
but nobody knows what the fuck's going on with me.
All right?
But I like,
you know,
this might surprise a lot of you guys.
I am not a fan.
I can't say I'm not a fan,
but I don't give a fuck about a level cities.
Okay.
Right.
Any city that you two tours too.
I don't give a shit about it.
All right.
At that point is blown out this cheesecake factories and fucking Dick Sporting
goods all over the fucking place.
It's all been devoured,
paved over those giant store windows that look like tropical fish tanks.
Now you know those things.
I like going to those fucking ones that you know,
the people that are in to you to have to drive from.
Why doesn't John Cougar Mellencamp error come to my city?
Um,
is there a reason why that guy always acts like he's a farmer?
Wasn't even like the glee club or something.
He's always acting like he's in the fucking west side story or some shit.
Ryan owners scare crow blown to plow.
Yeah,
you fucking play the Ukulele.
Stepped back like you were out there at fucking picking Avocados.
Whatever the fuck is.
You pretend that you did
say it at your job or horse should all make a rat.
He was the voice of the farmers long before all of these fucking stupid comic
started becoming the voice of fucking different causes.
You had this stupid musicians,
musicians doing it right.
What I love is no matter how much somebody,
when they're going to loan their celebrity,
what are you doing for this cause?
Famous person.
Well,
I am loaning by celebrity rehab.
Not going to use it for me in this moment and this moment I'm going to loan it
out to the common people.
The people have come to my movies and people ask for autographs,
okay?
The people that I walk past,
okay.
At airports,
uh,
my way to buy a private jet,
I am loaning my celebrity.
Whenever somebody loans they're slip,
it still ends up just just being about the celebrity,
isn't it?
You know,
glows.
Those fucking comedy horror.
You see it,
those fucking things,
right?
They're always up on the stage
then ever out in the crowd with the real fucking people.
Are they rubbing elbows with America?
Okay?
You don't look into the eyes staring at that fucking
yeah.
Post fucking,
what do you call Invisalign?
Dentition.
You don't even know what you're talking about anymore.
You know,
it's,
it's fucking point.
You don't even,
you don't even know what the fuck you looking at.
God bless people who are dating right now with Invisalign,
botox,
hair plugs.
You don't know.
You could be married off fucking troll.
You don't even know.
You don't even realize it,
Huh?
There should be something you shouldn't be allowed to fix yourself until after
you find love and you know what you're doing both people a favor.
So then you know it's real.
All these people in these fucking commercials late at night,
right?
I'm laying in bald son of a bitch,
top of my head,
ice cold against that fucking pillow,
right?
And I'm watching the TV at every five fucking seconds.
They got some fucking con coming out of a pool,
right?
With his fucking hair.
I'll wave it around.
He's playing fucking bad mitten.
Okay?
Live in this active lifestyle.
And everybody's always like,
well,
Gee,
I can't fuck a one.
I can't go for a swim unless I have hair plugs.
I can't play Badmouth.
That's not what it's about.
It's not about being active,
but showing that you can be active and you're not wearing a wig and it's not
going to come flying off.
Okay?
That's what used to happen back in the day,
people would get a wig.
Okay.
You know,
you decided you were getting a wig and then what you had to do was you had to
leave town,
okay.
And show up wearing your wig
and hope that they all bought it and all of a sudden you had a little more
confidence.
You talking to these beautiful check and everything's going fucking great,
right?
You're nervous on the first date.
You feel yourself sweating underneath your fucking toupee,
literally trickling down the back of your skull,
going into the back of your shirt and all you're thinking is,
thank God I wore a fucking sport coat.
All right,
cause I am sweating my fucking pits off right now,
you know?
Yeah.
And you fold them for a while then one day.
You know what I mean?
You get a little boozed up,
you get a little sloppy,
you know,
put the fucking tape on,
right.
Whatever you do.
I don't know how it sticks there.
I don't know if it's a little fucking,
I should look at that up.
I should look that up one day.
How to fucking put away God,
how to glue it to the top of your head,
but then,
then,
then all of a sudden,
all the advertising I'm going to be getting,
it's going to be like filos paint rollers with wig glue and that.
Now get your second roller for free
just in case she got some alopecia down there and your pube area,
we can get you,
we can give you a fucking pube wig.
A two for one,
two for one fucking wig down there by your pubes and up there on top of your
head.
We'll even throw in some eyebrows for you.
Um,
yeah,
you went to a new fucking town and then one day something happened.
You had to get involved in something,
some fucking four alarm fire and all they got is one fire house.
Next.
They know you're in the bucket brigade,
you start sweating.
Okay.
Maybe one of the amber,
Zara embers,
whatever you say,
fucking flies away from the fire and lands on top of that to pay.
And then it's like,
oh my God.
Okay.
I thought watching those people screaming from that burning building was the
most incredible thing I was going to see tonight until I saw your fucking wig
catch on fire.
Pull it off your fucking head.
And you went from 26 to 48 right in front of my eyes.
Who is his outlet outside or Honda's carpet bagger.
Do you guys were a big deal?
It was back in the day when a stranger moved to
cause you know there was no way to vet anybody.
He didn't know what the fuck was coming to town.
Okay.
You know,
is this a serial killer?
Is this person wanted,
is this a war criminal?
Did this person escaped from jail?
Did they just robbed a bank?
Okay.
Are they a scientologist?
Are they a a Mormon?
Okay.
Are they a Jehovah's witness?
Who is this guy and what the fuck's going on with this?
This something not right about them.
I can't figure out what the fuck it is.
And then we're all gossiping about you.
Assists smile on your face.
What is your buddy killed somebody I know something about something about him.
Something in his eyes
seem like there's something in his eyes.
I don't know what the fuck's wrong with them.
Is something going on with that fucking guy?
Yeah.
Then everybody starts talking and shit.
Nick.
See No,
people are drinking who we are.
Get fucking random.
I lock this town before it came.
When you get you walk down this tree,
not worry about some motherfucker was somewhere.
Look on his face.
We are a string them up.
Right.
And then they fucking go down and they grabbed the mother fucker or they write
as they put the rope around his head and he's screaming and yelling and he's
like,
alright,
I've got a wig.
I got her fucking wagon.
That was it.
And they took it off and all the towns,
people laughed at him and they tarred and feathered the top of his head.
The tide is fucking arms behind his back and they slapped that horse in the ass
and he was on the way to the next fucking town.
And that's the way it was.
That's the way America was back in the day,
you know.
And you know,
it's difficult as that is,
it is a part of our history.
It is kind of funny that people used to live a life like that.
Okay?
And you listened to what people complain about today and it all pales in
comparison,
okay?
To Ryan,
out of town on a horse she can't fucking control with the top of your skull,
tarred and feathered.
Alright,
this has been another episode.
Okay,
what are those fucking history,
those fuck ever listen to one of those fucking history podcast,
they tried to say that there was an entire field of skulls and bones still
existing in Russia.
He usually go there and it's really intense fucking talking and all.
It took me like two fucking Google searches to be like,
yeah,
that field doesn't exist.
Even if that wasn't true,
I want the guy was so fucking intense.
It just annoyed me.
It's like,
why are you taking on the intensity of this battle as though you fought it?
You didn't fight this fucking thing.
All right,
so why don't you bring your voice up a couple of fucking octaves still way you
normally talk and these people,
they came in Yangon.
Hey Gay fucking shit.
Like Tianya VFE this man beat this guy to death with a femur.
Um,
if you're going to beat somebody death with,
with a human bone,
you'd think he'd want the femur.
Yeah,
I think he'd want the femur.
If you could,
if the guy was far enough away and you could get sort of extension.
All right.
Other than that,
I,
you gotta go humorous.
Okay.
It's the second biggest bone.
It's an easier thing to swing.
It's better.
You know,
you can kind of also jab somebody in the face with it.
Famers a little too big for my tastes.
You know,
ladies,
you might go with the radius and Ulna.
You don't come in a little nunchuck thing.
You can put some chains between the two of them.
This is all things we're going to have to deal with in about,
I guess 30 years with global warming.
Um,
there's the world goes to hell in a fucking hand basket.
You know what's great about if you don't watch the news,
you think everything's fine.
Okay?
It's a great experiment because I spent a lot of time paying attention to the
news periods of my life and all I did was get freaked out and nothing changed
and nothing got better.
But if you don't pay attention
and he just sit there and you just,
I dunno.
Okay,
watch sports.
You can't even watch sports cause they drag it into that shit.
Now,
every fucking five seconds somebody's dying or something and they're bringing a
troop out of fucking firefighters.
You know,
I don't know.
Something.
There's always something.
Hey,
what do you enjoy in the game?
Will let us remind you how lucky you are.
We know how lucky we are.
How many fucking times,
Ladies and gentlemen,
a direct your attention to section two oh three some guy who got attacked by a
fucking pack,
a wild fucking toads,
Assam Shit.
Now I got to sit there and look at this fucking guy with his work comp coverage
face.
It's one of them stories makes you hold your kid a little,
little closer,
hug them a little tighter.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
I'm going to fly a cello copter tomorrow.
Can't wait,
haven't done that in a minute.
And uh,
they'll do that early in the morning and then I'm going to go in and I'm gonna
start working on this fucking script.
That's what I'm going to do.
Bill,
how's the pull ups coming?
We know you've been,
your shoulders have been slowly disintegrating and you've been trying to build
them up.
Um,
I actually lat pull downs,
I'm up to 120 pounds,
you know,
which is huge.
Coming back from rotator cuff fucking injury when you're in your 50.
So all I need to do is be able to do like three sets of 15,
and then I ought to be able to try one or two pull ups with my own body weight.
That's what I've been told.
All right,
so
I got a ways to go but a little bit of daylight there cause I got that bet with
Versie
the pride of New Jersey.
Yeah.
All right.
The Newark Native,
the uh,
the Trenton Teetotaller,
um,
that I won't be able to do 10 pull ups when I'm 70.
Okay.
So He's,
he's out of his fucking mind cause I will do fucking,
I'll do that stem cell shit into my shoulders just to fuck win that bet.
And stem cells is basically,
it's a hair transplant for your fucking shoulders.
Right?
Isn't that how it works?
It's so funny.
All these fucking people doing all this shit to try it live longer.
You know what I mean?
It's like I was trying to tell me,
he asked me the other day like,
when do you think the perfect time to be born was?
And um,
I would say somewhere in the 1940s.
So you miss out on World War II,
you miss out on the Korean conflict and he got Vietnam.
Right.
But if he can somehow get out of that,
as far as,
you know,
you got to live in some great decades.
Okay.
You still got to enjoy the four seasons,
you know,
things get,
didn't get too fucked up until like the late sixties.
Then I gotta I gotta be honest with you though,
being born in the 60s and being a kid in the 70s,
a teenager in the 80s and in my twenties and my nineties,
that's a pretty good ride.
Maybe everybody thinks that because they young,
I dunno.
I'm just sick of these fucking people coming up to me who aren't scientists
telling me when the world is going end.
Um,
it's like I get it.
I get it.
I got it.
Shit is fucked up please.
For the love of God.
Um,
I have a kid.
All right.
I'm trying to block that out because that's all my God,
this podcast just took a dark fucking turn.
Oh,
maybe I could sing your song.
The Sun will come out tomorrow and it will be a little hotter than fuck and
yesterday
and then you're done.
Gr Liverpool keeps winning and sodas,
Man City.
This has been one of the most boring things I've ever watched in sports because
knowing that these are the two best teams and they're never going to fucking
play each other in some sort of series.
Okay.
To figure it out.
This is like,
Hey,
you know,
I'm going to shadow box over here.
Well I'm shadow boxing over here and somehow we're fighting each other.
Okay.
I Dunno,
I just don't fucking understand that game.
Now I get the game.
Now I understand it more.
I just don't understand.
Like that's how you decide who's the fucking champion.
Okay.
Everything else.
Just the top two fucking people at least go out and kick the shit out of each
other and the web is left standing.
Wins.
Not In soccer.
Yeah.
Not In soccer when fucking trip and somebody makes them roll around that you
think you literally think they're on fire.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm still rooting for Liverpool.
I'm basically rooting from man,
not for Liverpool,
the beat Man City.
Cause they're not going to play each other now anymore.
I'm just rooting for Man City.
Not Win against an opponent that isn't Liverpool.
While Liverpool wins an opponent that isn't man city.
Oh,
that's exciting.
I can see why the world is into this game.
Then I get me some hate mail.
All right.
Oh look who's here.
I'll,
oh,
all set.
But crewed up.
Hiring used to be hard and it was so much harder for a woman.
Multiple job sites.
Forget about transitioning people.
They had the hardest time hiring people,
multiple job sites,
stacks of resumes,
a confusing review process.
But today,
hiring can be easy and you only have to go to one place to get it done.
Oh,
fucking gender neutral.
Zip
[inaudible] dot com slash birth um,
body of the deer we go.
Zip Recruiter sends your job to over 100 of the web's leading job boards.
But you know something,
most people would stop there,
but they don't stop there.
Nah,
that's ZipRecruiter with their powerful matching technology.
Okay?
They must be talking to people in ancestry.com zip recruiter's scans,
thousands of resumes to find people with the right experience and invites them
to apply to your job.
As applications come in,
I want to porn sites uses as applications come in,
ZipRecruiter analyzes each one and spotlights the top candidates.
So you never miss a great match.
And right now,
my listeners can try zip
for free.
Okay.
At this exclusive web address.
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that's ziprecruiter.com/burr Z I pee,
r,
e,
c r u,
I t e r.com/burb simple crooner.
This smartest way to hire the guys like to dramatic Paul.
I'm going to make dramatic pausing in my reading out loud.
Maybe I'll read out.
Read a little better.
Oh,
look who's here in,
don't Chino Indochino talk about people who would look even better in a suit.
Uh,
probably homeless people,
you know,
Christ.
They're filthy.
Then I gotta take a shower.
You might as well dress them up a little bit.
Looking to get married.
We have tons of options for those looking to outfit their wedding party.
Party guys love the wide selection of high quality fabrics and colors to choose
from.
Not to mention the option to personalize the details,
including your lapel lining pockets,
buttons,
and writing your own monogram.
Here's how it works.
Visit a stylist at our showroom and have them take your measurements personally
or measure it home yourself.
Get cheap.
Fuck and shop online@indochino.com uh,
to choose your fabric.
This is how it's written.
A lot of typos inside and out.
Choose your design and customization.
Submit your measurements without being judged with your choices.
Relax while you're suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a
couple of weeks.
I would love to meet the person who makes the suit this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 359 bucks@indochino.com
when entering bird at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's in no giant [inaudible] dot com promo code bird for any premium suit.
Just 359 bucks and free shipping.
Incredible deal for premium made to measure suit.
Once you go custom,
you never go back.
It's I n d o c h I n o.com.
All right,
stamps.com not funny was at watching Trump talking about wind.
I know the wind.
I know a lot about the wind.
Oh,
you don't understand the generator,
do you?
Dumb.
Fuck.
All right.
stamps.com no one really has time to go to the post.
Don't has time to do that bullshit.
It's just something you have to do.
You're busy,
right?
Even if you're not busy,
you don't get up and go do that.
What are you doing this weekend?
Oh,
I'm going to the post office.
Nobody says that.
You know you don't want to stand in that fucking line,
but he'll sit in that fucking traffic to go to the beach.
Won't yet.
Who's got time for all the traffic?
Oh,
there you go.
Parking,
lugging all your mail and packages.
Jesus.
Somebody needs a drink,
some whole milk.
I can't lug these envelopes.
It's a real hassle.
That's why you need stamps.com or the most popular timesaving tools for small
businesses,
stamps.com Briggs.
All amazing service.
All the amazing services of the US Postal Service,
right to your computer,
whether you're a small office sending invoices and online seller shipping our
products or even a warehouse,
sending thousands of packages a day.
stamps.com can handle it with the simply use your computer to print official us
postage,
24 seven for any letter,
any package,
any class a mail,
anywhere you want to send.
Once your mail is ready,
it is handed to your mail carrier,
not mailman,
not mail woman,
not male.
Gender neutral bathroom mail carrier.
All right,
and we're not talking about STDs or drop it in the mailbox.
Mailbox.
That's a little feminine,
right?
How come I can't be a male La Fallac?
Now it's that simple.
With stamps.com you get 5 cents off,
5 cents off every first class stamp and up to 40% off prioritized mail
stamps.com is a no brainer,
saving you time and money.
It's no wonder over 7,000 small businesses already used.
stamps.com right now our listeners,
my listener,
my listeners get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any long term commitment.
Just go to stamps.com click on the microphone top of the homepage and type in
bur bur that stamps.com enter Burr,
Bang,
boom.
Just like that,
the fucking advertising is over a,
I bought those Bruins.
You liked that play in Tampa.
Again,
we're playing Tampa Bay so smart.
This is what we do in the first,
the beginning of the game would come out.
We show them what we can do and then once they start thinking of,
fuck,
I don't want to meet these guys in playoffs.
We just fucking chill.
We just chill and let them score like four or five,
six fucking goals.
And now we got Tampa right where we want them.
Okay?
They one more goddamn games and scored more fucking points than anybody since
1995 when these fucking Goddamn,
you know,
blue and white cuts from the sunshine state really think that they're going to
fucking skate their way to the Stanley Cup.
I got news for you after we get done playing patty cake with the fucking Toronto
Maple leafs.
God Damn fucking asses.
All right,
we're going to be there,
right?
I would next round maybe two rounds.
Yeah,
but they ever fucking record.
All right.
Okay.
Right.
And then we're going to beat somebody else and then we're going to be there.
All right.
And we're going to do the exact same fucking thing,
you know,
and we'll lose four games straight to you.
And then your heads will not be barely be able to get your fucking helmets on
and then you're going to get the old right there.
Fred from my peck in the West having watched no hockey this year,
I'm going to pick the Nashville predators.
They got kind of close to the last few years.
Everyone's writing them off this year.
Hey,
why not them about the San Jose sharks.
How about for once?
How about for once they fucking pushed through the San Jose Sharks?
Don't win the fucking Stanley Cup this fucking year.
I know Carlos has got to get healthy.
Why don't they just fucking turn the names to the fucking dolphins?
You know the poor purposes be timely.
Score a goal.
You make that little fucking noise.
You know they should change the logo to a dolphin and then they and the dolphin
with its little flippers retape that stick back together that the fucking,
the shark bit naff.
I think that that's half the problem.
It's their fucking logo is the referee see it and then they just start calling
slashing cause they see a stick been broken.
And obviously that's must have been what happened,
right?
Brooklyn Nets made the playoffs in the Houston Rockets scored a 27 hit 27 three
pointers tonight.
Um,
none of these teams could fucking beat the fucking 83 Milwaukee Bucks.
But you know,
but it's a different game.
Dodgers,
a score and a bunch of runs.
There's a lot of stuff happening.
I missed all of it.
I had family town family down for bad Logan.
MMM.
All right.
Where do we go from here?
No booze in 19 weeks.
You know what a fucking break up that was.
Thank God I'm not a fucking week alcoholic.
Okay.
They're fucking fine.
40 people listen to my stupid fucking stories.
Like those people that have been sober for like 30 fucking 40 years.
Okay.
Oh,
boring.
And their stories at that point is sitting there till in drunk stories from
fucking back in the day.
Yeah.
Oh,
I remember there was origin Howard here,
judge or lectured.
I don't know where it's coming back from a sock hop.
I'm buying gold and I went to the whites only found and I took out a flash.
All right.
Buying gold?
A dear Billy throwback.
Okay.
Was listening to an old podcast where you said you were going to buy gold
because the economy was unstable.
Oh yeah.
It was a little unstable.
Yes.
10 years ago.
Yeah.
I would say it was a little unstable.
I'd say I had my finger on the pulse a year after the big fucking crash,
uh,
two years at that point.
Um,
did you ever buy gold to stash away in case our currency crashed?
Why would I say that on the podcast?
Uh,
I think some people are treating bitcoin in the same way.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Ah,
yeah.
I thought about doing that and then until I found out how fucking difficult it
is to buy gold coins.
Okay.
It's very hard to get your hands on some gold.
And then what?
And then I just realized,
you know,
if I have a fucking gold coin,
what am I going to do with it?
So say the dollar crashes and nobody has any money,
then I'm walking down the street with a bag of gold coins.
Nobody has any money,
they can't pay anybody.
And that is a guy from the sandwich store going to fucking show up,
also known as a deli.
Is he gonna show up at the Deli and I'm going to come walking in as he's not
getting paid and then I have a gold coin and going to get me fucking changed for
that.
Does that,
he told me we'll get some silver coins and are worth as much.
Yeah.
I don't,
I,
you know something,
I don't need that fucking headache.
MMM.
You got gold coins,
which you want to do is trade that in for some fucking cyanide pills.
Okay.
And then when everything goes to shit and people are coming up your driveway
that,
you know,
like your written that fucking movie us,
Eh,
you just fucking,
you take your,
uh,
you kill me pills.
I think that's the way they do it.
You know,
get a flat screen TV and on all four walls of every fucking room you have,
just blow out the fucking ozone layer as much as you can.
And when the shit goes to hell,
you know,
just watch it on all your TVs and you know,
when you recognize the helicopters surveillance footage and you're like,
oh fuck,
that's my house.
So they right outside,
then you take your pills or you get a panic from,
okay,
you build a panic room.
Yeah.
But they could still smoky out.
I would think.
There's always a way in.
I think what you do,
I liked the underground shit.
I think that's the way to go when people take,
you know,
basically in all his shit things that they,
um,
unload from those fucking ships down at the wharf and then they stick them on
the back of a truck,
18 wheeler chassis,
you know,
those things up from the second season of the wire and they find all those
fucking poor people in there.
Right.
Spoiler alert,
the second season of the wire from fucking 15 years ago.
Um,
I liked the people,
they,
they get those things Barry.
Okay.
But the problem is,
okay,
the problem is,
is you got to dig the hole yourself because if you hire a contractor with a
backhoe,
yeah.
Sorry,
just yawn there.
He's going to be asking all kinds of questions.
Well,
are you really doing here man?
You fucking,
you make in a lap pool or Sheldon?
No,
I just need get rid of the ex wife.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Nah.
People would figure it out.
Let's say that's the way you dress,
the way you kill your wife.
You know,
cause they always say they never,
they never dig lower than like six feet.
Hm.
Maybe you watch all those murder she wrote unsolved fucking that murder she
wrote.
What are those unsolved murder?
Fucking the first 48
they're always burying people in a shallow grave and they always get fucking
caught.
Or they just dump it in the woods just shoddy of all the fucking times to not
dot all your i's and cross all your t's when you're dumping a fucking body.
You know,
if he just didn't kill somebody in,
in a crime of passion,
if you actually premeditating the fuck the dig the hole first
and get go lower than fucking,
you know,
yeah,
go lower than six feet.
You got all fucking dead person's alive that we live for a long fucking time.
He got all fucking day.
Go down 10 feet.
10 fucking feet.
Right?
That's what you do.
You go cool hand Luke times like fucking three.
Okay.
Can you fucking,
I'm going to fucking alluded ticks around.
Can you imagine digging a fucking hole for somebody that you know you're going
to kill you?
Not In the middle of digging that all gone.
Fuck am I doing?
Why don't I find it another fucking so why don't I just,
you know,
fight the guy.
Well I just let it go,
you know,
go have a couple of fucking beers or something like that.
Okay,
I'm going to kill this person and then risk going to jail for life and then
having to join.
Then at that point,
you know,
then what do you do?
You're a white dude.
You just killed somebody.
Now you gotta go through the pain in the ass,
a fucking go into the prison library and Cram it on Adolf Hitler.
So you can come off as a legit Nazi and join the fucking Arie and brotherhood.
And then you've got to listen to the head dumb shit every fucking day for the
rest of your life.
You know,
you'd think an AA meetings bad when you just a binge drinker.
Man,
why do you fucking try that shit?
What just happened in my head?
Phones.
Everything was good.
Now I can't hear myself.
Hello?
Is it still going?
What happened?
I literally just moved.
Oh God.
Don't don't do this to me.
Sam is such a fun time and then all of a sudden I can't hear myself.
Oh the,
I see what happened.
I moved in.
The wire turned the volume down.
You guys were all panicking there.
Oh Christ.
This fucking guy with no producer.
He's not going to be able to figure it out because my fucking laptop is losing
its charge.
No fucking I can't move over here cause my headphone cord is too short.
You know you wouldn't,
you wouldn't think that I'm 10 years into this podcast listening to this and
these,
these fucking technology fucking problems be fucking person that I started out
with the started doing a podcast.
They fucking build some Howard stern level studio or some version of it.
You know what I mean?
I'm like the native American of fucking podcasting,
you know,
they just lived the same way.
Essentially.
Least that's what the history books say.
You know,
they just fucking,
this is how you kill a deer or this is how you use all of it.
All right?
You want it these fucking,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious.
All these fucking douchebag white people out there fucking with this stupid
ideas about minimalism acting like they came up with that shit.
What the native Americans can the fuck this mother fucking God damn fucking sue
the fuck came up with the,
now I don't do this anymore.
That's it right there.
It goes to floor number four and then that's it.
Who the fuck came up with this stupid fucking magnet?
Fucking plug on the God Damn Apple Computer.
Stupid fucking cons.
Okay.
Have you ever seen the apple building,
by the way?
There's so many fucking companies.
They're just out of control then.
Fuck.
It looks like the Pentagon.
No,
it doesn't build to circle.
The Pentagon is a 40
I just realize as far as shapes gold,
how dumb that sounded.
Okay.
I saw this round building.
You know what it looked like to me,
the Pentagon.
Hey,
who went to summer school for math almost every fucking year.
This guy,
this guy who's a fucking stupid fucked up
fucking assholes.
Stupid magnet.
You want me to fucking times.
I bet a replug that thing.
And do you want me to stand as a person living in a first world country that
that's the most difficult thing I have to deal with.
I can't imagine the sad person that makes us fucking plug.
MMM.
How funny is it that they go after comedians for jokes and all these fucking
yeah,
Goddamn company sampling like sweatshop labor and that's all fine.
That's all fine.
Well,
if we made the computer year,
they'd caught $90 million.
No they wouldn't.
They wouldn't.
If you actually paid people and you paid and gave them benefits and you took it
out of your end,
you don't anybody to say that?
Well,
we could make shirts here,
but they cost $700 each.
It's like,
how little are you paying people to sell these things together?
Cause they're not going to take a pay cut because they going to stay on their
yacht with their mountain of cocaine and they're fucking horse.
Okay.
That's the biggest problem with the fucking world is horse will fuck anything if
it has money.
Okay.
Maybe of Horseheads standards.
All of these fucking guys wouldn't be fucking doing whatever I'm doing.
Whatever it takes,
doing whatever it takes to get a fine piece of fucking pussy that never did
anything other than suck my dick sit next to me on my yard with my fucking name
stitched into the fucking seat.
Okay.
Oh,
is there anything better than when a yard sinks other than the crew?
it's just my favorite thing ever.
It just doesn't happen enough.
Just doesn't happen enough.
You know?
Can you imagine that you're sleeping in the bowels of that thing,
like the things you had to do to get that fucking yard and all of a sudden you
start taking on water and the radio isn't working and for the first time in
years you're thinking about a higher power.
And all the sins you have to fucking confess to how fast are you fucking
yammering is you start to feel the water coming up around you fucking
sheepskin fucking slippers.
Whatever the fuck rich people have,
everybody can have sheepskin bill sheepskins gets not expensive.
All right.
Probably some endangered species of baby seal.
Fucking slippers would've been a better reference.
Whatever next podcast,
I'll get it.
Next podcast.
Um,
yeah,
so I got into conspiracy theory and all of that type of shit,
but I got into the,
I got into the scary part of a conspiracy theory.
I was reading about shit that was actually happening and then people's theories
about it.
I wasn't reading about,
you know,
shape shifters and,
and fucking the government actually has a flying saucer in,
in the area of 51 or whatever the fuck it,
all.
That shit was just like,
Oh really?
Okay,
whatever.
I got more into the economies and banking and Nah,
uh,
you know,
corporate greed and uh,
okay.
Politicians and our,
the whole fucking thing works and offshore accounts and just all of this crap.
I get into that stuff.
I didn't get into late,
you know,
who were actually aliens,
uh,
that were dropped by a fucking flying saucer and they're watching us.
It's a big experiment.
I didn't get into that.
The government has time machines and uh,
the former youth going to come with it.
I never got to like fucking crazy shit,
build a burg and stuff like that.
That did fascinate me.
I did get into that shit and then after a while I just became this fucking
person who wouldn't stop talking about it and I had no the fuck out of everybody
and I had enough of a need to be like that.
I said,
all right.
All right,
I'm with you guys.
Back to the ignorant masses.
I went back,
not that I was informed,
but it was part of the other thing.
I just got back to the ignorant masses and supposedly ignorant conspiracy
theorist,
ignorant meeting.
Just uninformed.
Not Stupid.
All right.
I went back to the ignorant masses.
Hey ladies,
laser John.
By the way,
out.
Sabato was attacked by a pit bull and survivor of Rah Rah,
Rah and blossom.
Uh,
he's wearing a pink dog collar for Teddy Cancer.
Um,
all right.
The goal,
the age of TV sucks.
All right,
deal.
Dear Billy Tube.
I know they've dubbed this the golden age of television.
Well,
they would have to accurately call it the second golden age of television
because the first golden age,
I believe was back in the 1950s and the people who called it the golden age
where the white people making the television for other white people.
Right.
Uh,
but I eat,
an person says,
I really hate it.
Of course I enjoy some of the shows that are coming up or overall,
I don't enjoy the experience.
I hate having to select a show on a menu.
It makes it that much easier for me to change it.
15 minutes.
And if I'm not impressed,
dude,
I'm with you.
I'm going back to reading.
I like it better.
I pick up a book,
I read a little bit,
I get sleepy,
I go to sleep done over,
over the,
these fucking streaming services,
you know,
God bless him.
I know the kids love him and I'm old enough for me.
I find it overwhelming and I keep saying,
oh buddy,
am I going,
you know,
some of these streaming things,
it reminds me of a,
Robin Williams made this movie called Moscow on the Hudson,
which I'm sure is on Netflix,
Amazon,
fucking apple,
all these Disney,
all these fucking places that stream HBO and there's a scene he from Russia.
Okay.
You know where the stereotype was?
Everybody had to stand in line and the black market sergeants at the lamp here.
Um,
okay.
And there weren't a lot of choices.
So many defects.
The first time he goes to a supermarket and he sees all the choices he has,
he gets so overwhelmed that he faints.
Well,
that's basically,
I mean,
I don't faint,
but when I go on like a streaming service thing,
I get overwhelmed by the sheer amount of choices that,
uh,
most of my time on the streaming service I spend scrolling through shit.
And in the end I just go,
you know what?
Fuck this.
It's literally like,
do you know,
like when you got to do your taxes in for an entire year,
you just through every your seat into this box and there's no organization to it
whatsoever.
And then one day you got to open it up and you just,
you don't even know where the fuck to begin.
Uh,
that's how I feel.
So,
um,
I am a big believer now and getting back,
I'm just going to try to get back into reading and I walk away from my phone
now.
I tried for a couple of hours each day.
I just,
I just haven't,
you know,
shut off or somewhere else and I gotta be honest.
I'm not missing anything.
I've never
okay
had any sort of urgent
call or anything or any opportunity that I missed.
And it's Kinda nice to just sort of fucking walk away from it.
And then when he come up to your phone after a couple hours is kind of exciting
because you have all these fucking text messages so he can get right back and
get a nice hit of the crack.
It's kind of Nice.
It's kind of a nice thing.
Um,
so if you've noticed a change in me,
um,
as I explore being sober,
I want you guys to know that I promise you I will continue to get more and more
preachy
I'm going to be doing,
I just feel like for me,
reading and being conscious of a higher power,
how many people have said that while we're in like fucking red bottom shoes?
Um,
that's one of my favorite characters out here in Hollywood.
The caring whore used to be the horror with a heart of gold.
Now it's the caring whore.
Okay.
You ever heard of the giving tree?
The sequel is the caring whore.
All right.
Uh,
slavery in Libya.
I'm gonna alone by Botox faced celebrity influencer.
Okay.
Instagram page to this cause cause I just feel that guy just so totally just
like,
hey,
I gotta tell you something.
I was listening to Howard stern
the other day and he was doing this fucking thing about one of these bachelor's
shows.
And this guy had,
I had never heard anybody say this because I learned this back when I was at
Emerson College.
Vocal fry vocal fry.
Basically.
It basically occurs when you're not pushing enough air through your voice box
and it causes you to talk like this.
And it's really weird because when people,
when they start to get more intense,
they're still not pushing enough air and it just gets louder and it's really
fucking annoying.
He's want to take a firehose and jam it down their fucking throat.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
okay.
He was talking about this person on the show,
this guy who add vocal fry and they were some,
I don't know how the fuck they did this,
but they started playing
lamb of God and I love that band,
but they were just playing the singer singing without any of the instruments and
just,
just his vocal track.
I was fucking dying laughing because it fits perfectly with the band and the
band is fucking awesome and I love it.
But when you just take that guy out by himself,
like I was fucking punching the steering wheel.
I was laughing so hard.
So if you guys can somehow find that I haven't,
I'll do a little search.
You'll see if it's available to save you some fucking time.
If you drive any new car here.
Let's see here.
Um,
how were stern lamb of God vocal track?
Let me see if this comes up.
Okay.
MMM.
Ban.
It doesn't,
Oh fuck you.
It was,
it was the one of the great,
I dunno,
I'm sure somebody who knows how to search better than me.
Um,
I'm going to start sharing my seeker,
um,
slavery in Libya.
Okay.
Uh,
dear Billy elect.
Um,
have you heard about how much of a fuck show Libya is ever since the Hillary
Clinton brought down Kadafi how did she do it?
I didn't know she did that they had,
that's the latest thing to blame her for a,
they had a complete breakdown in,
they're already suffering society.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
They have open air slavery.
Oh,
you got to hate when it,
when it goes outside,
you know,
as long as it's inside,
I think,
you know,
open air slavery,
Jesus,
I could get contagious and it's got so bad that the u s troops had the pull out
because it wasn't safe for them.
Now,
the person gave me a link,
but it was to,
uh,
the Washington Post and then I got to read like half an article and they got me
interested in.
Then they're like,
hey man,
if you want to read the rest of us,
why don't you subscribe?
Oh my gosh,
your dollar big boy.
Um,
so I had to go to some other site and try to figure out what the fuck's going on
there.
He said,
it makes no sense that we do this shit other than
someone powerful controls our armies to help their business interests.
Uh,
you know,
you had such a great point to make and you left out some word.
It makes words.
It makes no sense that we do this shit
other than
someone powerful controls our armies to help their business interests.
Yeah.
Well Libby is saying that is bullshit.
They're saying this is just a smear campaign,
which the world is so fucked up right now.
I would actually listen to that.
Like,
okay,
well now are we using this as an excuse to invade them?
But it seems like we're leaving.
I Dunno.
Are these people that are being enslaved,
are they lucky enough to be being enslaved on land that has a lot of oil
underneath it?
Because if it does,
the calvary is common,
which is regular earth with dirt underneath it.
Uh,
yeah,
they're in trouble,
man.
It's fucked up.
I,
it's,
well this is one of the stories.
I read a little bit about it.
That's why I try not to,
uh,
look at this shit,
which I know,
isn't that what he's supposed to do?
He's supposed to stay informed and try to help fellow human beings.
Um,
I dunno.
I gotta be honest with you.
It was super depressing.
The pictures and everything that I saw it and it just makes no sense to me that
I get lucky enough to be born where I am and how I look.
Not Saying I'm good looking and saying I got lucky enough to be born a white
dude and
what the fuck wrong thing that they do.
They're born in different parts of the world.
Look different.
Nobody fucking wants him in the air.
The refugees,
I dunno.
It's a fucking shame.
I have no idea how to stop it.
Um,
if anybody has any suggestions.
by the way,
I'm still trying to set up a charity for a fucking local high school.
I can't believe how fucking difficult it is.
Trying to find a fucking place to do it where I can also dictate where I want
the money to go.
Finding an ice school to do a charity,
it is not that difficult,
but finding one that's that,
that you can actually say,
okay,
now this is just going to go to this,
right?
This isn't going to go to the teacher's lounge.
Fucking
we bank for spring break.
All right.
Wife won't let me drive.
Okay.
A buddy.
I got to tell you something right now.
MMM.
The uphill battle you're going to have with me to this next paragraph is shit
that I'm going to read is trying to somehow win back my respect.
All right.
Why won't let you drive?
The only way I respect in this situation is if you're a fucking raging alcoholic
missing at least two,
if not three limbs.
Other than that I,
I dunno.
Did you lose your balls in a farming accident that John Cougar Mellencamp right,
right.
A fucking song about your testes.
All right,
Bill.
I'm in a very strange situation.
My wife and I have seven years have not been getting along very well.
Um,
then the last year or so it's gotten worse.
Well,
you need to work on it,
dude.
You got to work on it.
It's hard,
man.
Marriage is work.
Uh,
we argue all the time mainly because she starts fighting fights over everything.
She doesn't respect me at all and she's always comparing me to other guys she
works with.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I was already a red flag when she fights over everything.
This sounds like miss directed.
Okay.
I would say topic anger.
She is mad at you or maybe she's mad at herself from Mary when she does,
I dunno.
Anyways,
last month someone backed into me in a parking lot and dented my car a bit.
She told me it was my fault for not being a responsible enough driver,
even though it happened while I was 10 feet away.
Okay.
In the already parked car.
What?
So now when we go places,
she demands to drive because I'm not a strong enough driver.
This clearly,
this is to clearly emasculate me.
I'm planning on filing for divorce,
but I have to get my affairs in order to first,
do you have any advice on how to deal with this in the meantime?
Thanks.
All right.
This is a hail Mary.
Yeah,
they hail Mary is,
you got to,
this is possibly,
might have to do with the way you conduct yourself and your business.
And that's why she lost respect for you.
And she wants you to fucking man up.
So she's pushing your buttons to see if he got any man in.
Yeah,
I might be wrong.
She might just say in order to be banging somebody work.
All right,
but the Hail Mary here,
you know,
I don't know.
I think you got to fuck the shit out of.
You got to put one on her.
You got to dicker down,
dude.
That's what you gotta do.
Okay,
you got it.
You got to bring that fucking,
uh,
you know,
back from overseas.
Dick.
That's what you got it.
You got to come at her with that.
If that doesn't get her fucking motor running again,
then I think this is a wrap.
But um,
yeah,
it's some point a long time ago you should have put your foot down and Ben like,
shut the fuck up.
I'm driving my own car.
If you don't want know,
sit in the fucking back seat.
Okay.
Deploy the airbag before we even go if you want.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm drive and go fuck yourself.
Um,
okay.
All right.
Well you filed for divorce.
It doesn't seem like there's any kids or whatever,
but it's just like,
I would just,
I'd sit down and I'd ask her and be like,
can I ask you a question?
Like,
why?
Why are you fucking mad at me all the time?
And I gotta be honest with you.
Start,
stop being,
stop being such a bitch.
Jesus Christ your fucking car.
What do you like an accountant and she's like a up and coming MMA and you're
worried she's gonna kick the shit out of you.
Then I understand that
bad enough.
She's driving your car,
you don't have to put you in a fucking triangle,
right.
Or worst spinning back fist.
Oh,
that'd be the fucking worst,
right.
By the kitchen island.
You know,
whack your head on the corner of it.
Wake up covered in fruit loops in a broken cereal bowl.
You can't have that.
Can't have that.
Um,
yeah,
that would be my instinct.
I would stand up for myself and I would,
uh,
you know,
do you remember when that dude in that movie?
Fuck that chick on the stairs.
You remember the one I'm talking about,
right?
That history of violence.
Yeah.
You got to come with the hitman.
He was,
uh,
he was coming.
He was given to the family man.
Dick.
Up until then,
I'm all overrated.
Uh,
responsibilities.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated for the week.
Uh,
overrated responsibilities.
Bill,
I've started streamlining my life and I don't do and deal with shit.
I don't,
uh,
I don't deal with shit.
I want to what you guys do.
Voice Tech sees things.
I've started streaming my life and I don't do and deal with shit.
I want to,
I don't even know where to go with that.
Do I have to fix this?
I started streaming living my life.
I don't do shit.
I don't want to.
Okay.
I don't do or deal with shit.
I don't want to,
I think is what he's trying to say.
I recently changed companies and have a job that is lower on the totem pole but
pays more on the fuck.
Did you do that?
I used to think I wanted to be a boss.
I don't.
Good man.
Smart man.
I want to make money and have flexible hours.
Have have flexible hours.
He wrote it twice.
He's so committed to this.
Fuck your big goals.
Bill,
burr key podcasting and find yourself a nice rocking chair.
MMM.
Well I dunno why my goals should fucking affect you.
I like how the fact that I have big goals.
I don't have big goals.
I got a little freckled red goals.
When they're my goals,
they're mine.
How dare you,
how I'm living my truth.
Um,
keep podcasting and find yourself a nice rocket chair.
Dude.
If you don't fucking think that I'm not trying to work towards that.
I've gotten way,
way,
way more fucking busier than I ever wanted to be.
Everyone had to be.
I wanted to do all this shit that I'm doing,
but I had no fucking idea how much time it took.
And now that I know that I am stepping back,
I am assessing the situation.
MMM.
As Fun as my life is this,
there's nothing better than being at home with my wife and my kid.
My funniest thing my kids doing now,
right there is a
yeah.
Is when she knows she's going to bed and all the things she tries to do to
extend her time up.
Like,
I'll,
I'll brush teeth,
brush teeth,
you know,
uh,
close your doors,
close your doors.
[inaudible] we read a book,
we book.
Oh,
She goes,
oh.
And then he just sit there,
go,
no,
honey,
it's time to go to bed.
Tired,
go to bed.
And then she tries to cry,
but she's not crying.
She just goes,
ah,
like fucking Lucille Ball.
It's hilarious.
Um,
but we still give it a little bubba with the in and when she sees that,
that's her scotch for the night,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
yeah.
Believe me,
dude,
believe me,
if I,
if I could figure out a way to get off the fucking wheel,
it's not how it works.
So it's not how it works,
then I can have a bunch of fucking people retiring at 50.
They keep,
well,
they want to keep making money.
What they do is like,
all right,
we're going to keep,
they keep taking a bite out of your ass.
You know,
the only way you weren't tired.
Fifties.
If you have some disease and you know,
you're gonna be dead at 54,
that's the only way I see how to do it.
You know,
and there's all downsides.
You laugh,
go live in a fucking trailer and,
and,
and then what?
As they constantly come up with new ways to fucking tax people,
my nest egg,
they'll,
they'll go after it.
It's fucking Lee.
They little this literally Americans right now,
co-signing signing on taxing fellow Americans,
70% on fucking earned income.
Honest fucking Americans as they look the other way on $20 trillion in untaxed
evil fucking non tax paying American cons money sitting in the fucking Cayman
Islands,
that's too much of a hassle.
They don't want to take the fucking bag all the way to the curb.
They're going to sit on the couch and fucking picker some regular dude off.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
anyways,
I don't.
Good,
good for you buddy.
If you can figure out how to do it,
if you can figure out how to do it.
And I would say one of the biggest things you want to streamline your life is do
not have a woman in your fucking life because they cannot stop buying shit.
It's,
it's insane.
It is fucking insane.
And whoever came up with the mall is a fucking genius because that shit is just
visual fucking crack to most women just walk and meandering around those things.
What do they about this?
Does this look cute?
They encourage you thought you should get it.
You are so,
oh my God,
you should totally get that.
I guide tie dye.
Okay,
fucking dopes.
And all they do is sit there saying that they should,
you know,
hey ladies,
maybe you should earn the same amount as a man to see what the same job.
When you can show yourself to be a little more fiscally responsible,
what do you want to make?
Can you imagine if I said this at a woman's college?
God,
I Miss Doing College gigs.
Um,
yeah,
ladies,
maybe,
you know,
if he didn't fucking buy something off of Amazon every fucking two days,
okay,
maybe then maybe then Uncle Sam will give you more money.
I don't even know if that's even fucking true that they make less money.
I Dunno.
I could tell you right now,
if they got paid by the world word,
they fucking run the world.
Ah,
Jesus Bell.
Come on.
Let's not start to,
let's not do this.
Let's keep it happy.
Okay?
It's almost Easter,
isn't it?
Easter bunnies out there will be doobie doe and he's hopping around like a
fucking freak.
Who wants a fucking chocolate egg?
Do you know?
I never had the balls to try a Cadbury egg.
Okay.
I was always confused.
I thought it was a real egg.
I didn't understand that there was some sort,
I would guess some sort of custard.
All right.
We're going to end this podcast by finally finding out what the fuck it was so
weird there.
That God damn rabbit.
One point,
point,
point.
Point.
Remember that?
Cad burry eggs.
Okay.
What is in them?
I got to be the dumbest person on the fucking Internet.
Okay.
A Cadbury egg is a chocolate confection.
Hang on a second.
What is kind of affection?
Okay.
Confection a dish or delicacy made with sweet ingredients.
Oh,
you mean candy?
Okay,
thank you.
I can recreate.
An egg is a chocolate confection produced in the shape of an egg.
All right,
so it's just a desert.
They have it in the shape of an egg originating from the British British
chocolate tier Cadbury.
You make chocolate.
Oh,
scares me,
boy.
I like chocolate a.
The product consists of thick chocolate shell.
Okay.
It is what we need.
Housing,
the sweet white and yellow fondant filling.
Okay.
What's
fondant?
Sounds like it would come out of a fountain.
It'd be a bunch of chicks dip and shit into it.
Fondant technologies,
wait a minute.
Found out is the most popular cake decoration topping.
It can be colored and easily shaped.
What the fuck is what is in fondant?
Fondant?
I spelled it wrong.
Phone is a type of icing.
It's icing
fondant.
Kim.
Refer to two types of sugar base pace used in preparing decorating cakes,
pastries,
confections.
I said fucking word again.
Confection.
Feel like a fucking don't want us a sleuth right now for desserts.
Fondant filling,
which mimics the album in it.
Okay,
what is this is fucking insane.
Owl Boom,
and I spelled it right.
M e n n m.
A N
album man,
the white of an egg.
Okay,
let's put this in layman's term.
A Cadbury creme egg is a chocolate dessert produced in the shape of an egg
originating from the British chocolate guys.
Cadbury.
The product consists of a thick chocolate shell housing,
a sweet yellow icing filling,
which mimics the
egg yolk white.
Now though the white egg,
white and yolk of a chicken egg there,
now I know what the fuck it is.
Should I do an Instagram video of me actually eating one of those fucking
things.
Good.
God Almighty.
Who would the fuck thought of that?
It's kind of creative.
Yeah.
Then they had the fucking,
it was always threw me off.
I always thought it was a fucking egg,
but you know what,
then good.
You know what?
Hat's off to those chocolate tiers because you fooled me for fucking 30 years.
I thought it was a fucking egg.
All right.
I know you're never going to get those fucking four minutes back.
William.
I apologize.
I'll do a benefit for all of you,
okay.
For your living your truth.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll check it on you on Thursday.
Stanley Cup playoffs.
F One MLB,
NBA playoffs,
moto GP.
The exciting conclusion to premiere league soccer.
Well,
the two best teams are on a collision course to not play each other.
Um,
all right,
I'll see you Thursday.